alors en fait samedi je revenais
tranquillement de courses au centre
ville de Strasbourg vous avez pris de
l'essence une voiture électrique
comme vous êtes de quel bord je suis LR
d'accords
[Musique]
les jeunes viennent et les plus vieux
qui qui font 4% ils viennent plus merci
non mais c'est un mec qui est plus là
le conseiller là l'ouvrier là
bon alors donc je reviens de course en
ville et je reçois de nombreux
témoignages par mes réseaux sociaux par
message en me disant bah il y a un
cortège qui qui est en train de
s'élancer dans la ville et des voitures
qui bloquent carrément des rues pour les
privatiser faire des excès de vitesse
avec des berlines louées en Allemagne et
ne respectait aucune règle du code de
sur la route franchir des feux
tricolores passer en sens interdit
certains riverains qui tentaient un
moment quand même de calmer le jeu bah
ce sont fait happer les gens faisaient
comme s'ils allaient les renverser donc
il y a beaucoup de riverains qui ont été
quand même assez choqués par cette scène
et surtout des coups de feu et on
n'était pas on ne savait pas à ce
moment-là le type de coup de société
puisqu'on savait pas si c'était un
pistolet d'alarme ou pas les habitants
ils ont ils ont flippé ils ont tous eu
vraiment très très peur et c'est pour ça
que moi je me suis rendu immédiatement à
la mairie puisque c'est un de mes
adjoints qui devaient célébrer le
mariage c'est pas vous qui devez céder
et donc je suis allé tout de suite à la
mairie et quand je suis arrivé à la
mairie j'ai assisté à la scène où la
brigade antique criminalité interpellé
les les trois les trois personnes à
l'intérieur du véhicule et notamment le
porteur de l'arme puisqu'on ne savait
pas à ce moment-là quel type d'armes ça
pouvait être et s'il y avait un réel
danger justement par rapport à cette
arme c'était c'était des amis du marié
ou de la mariée qui était c'était le
frère du marié frère du mari qui portait
cette arme qui a été interpellé et il y
avait il y avait eu pas mal
d'infractions au code de la route qui
avait été relevé et d'ailleurs les on
est en train d'exploiter les vidéos de
surveillance parce que il y a quand même
toutes ces infractions aujourd'hui qui
restent impunies alors donc la brigadary
anti criminalité elle arrive à la mairie
donc là elle interpelle qui alors elle a
interpelle les donc le frère c'est ça
les frères et les deux passagers puisque
on sait pas à ce moment-là qui attiré
qui a tiré tirs ou des fautir c'est ça
et on sait pas quel type d'armes c'est
donc forcément c'est la brigade anti
criminalité qui est qui est qualifiée
pour ça en général c'est plutôt eux qui
sont envoyés sur ce type d'inspiration
mais on a un dispositif avec déjà au
moins une quinzaine de policiers qui
arrivent alors on va des motards enfin
c'est déjà assez impressionnant donc ça
met une ambiance quand même autour de la
mairie que j'avais jamais
et donc et donc et donc j'arrive et donc
je prends contact avec l'officier de
police qui était à ce moment-là en
charge de cette de cette interpellation
et je lui dis bah écoutez moi je prends
la décision d'annuler le mariage il faut
que j'aille voir mon adjoint et pour
rentrer à l'intérieur de la mairie comme
il y avait déjà un certain nombre
d'invités qui était à l'intérieur de la
mairie dans la salle des mariages je me
suis retrouvé à devoir rentrer dans ma
propre mairie entourée de policier pour
justement ne pas avoir de menaces envers
ma personne ce qui est quand même je
vous l'avoue un tout petit peu choquant
parce que franchement moi j'ai célébré
déjà pas mal de mariage ça fait deux ans
que je suis mère donc on célèbre les
mariés ou pas non je les connaissais pas
du tout donc franchement voilà sans ils
habitent où ils habitent dans votre
ville il y a il y a une partie qui
habite à Illkirch la mariée d'accord
donc c'était la mairie de la mariée
c'est ça et donc voilà moi j'arrive
adjoint vous lui avez dit quoi on fait
pas le mariage en fait j'ai dû j'ai dû
faire venir mon adjoint on a été mis
dans une pièce de la mairie protégée par
la police pour pouvoir discuter parce
que la police avait peur justement qu'à
un moment ça puisse s'envenimer et la
police nous a dit ben ok pour
l'annulation mais il faut patienter on
va appeler des renforts pour pouvoir
évacuer
puisque on n'a pas procédé à la à la
cérémonie donc aujourd'hui il y a pas eu
d'annulation de l'acte de mariage
puisqu'il a pas été prononcé mais dans
ces conditions moi j'estime qu'avec une
mairie qui envahit finalement par tout
plein de force de police on n'est pas
dans des conditions optimum quand même
pour pouvoir procéder à des mariés on va
voir votre version après on va voir la
version de l'avocat c'est la version les
mariés ont été assez déçus forcément
mais je dois dire et je tiens à le
reconnaître quand même parce qu'il faut
être tout à fait honnête dans ses
affaires là tout s'est passé dans le
calme alors il y avait un fort
dispositif de police mais tous ces
parassé dans le calme on a une
discussion qui était tout à fait apaisée
j'ai une discussion avec les membres de
la famille mais je leur ai expliqué ma
décision et pourquoi j'avais pris cette
décision alors passez votre version
mettre Monsieur Philippe pas encore
maître je peux rajouter un thé
mettre Mohamed Achour vous êtes donc
l'avocat du couple de mariée
vous est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter votre version des faits ma
version des faits en fait elle diffère
un petit peu de celle de Monsieur le
Maire
globalement en fait ce qui s'est passé
donc ça a été raconté donc on a eu en
fait ce cortège là ce qu'il faut savoir
en fait c'est que la mariée habite sur
la commune de Illkirch mais pour se
rendre à la mairie on a à peu près pour
aller entre 3 et 5 minutes d'accord donc
quand on parle en fait de rodéo on a lu
dans la presse on a eu dans presque qui
avait des incivilités je dis pas il y a
forcément eu des infractions au code de
la route ça arrive régulièrement en fait
dans ce type dans ce type dans ce type
de cortège mais il y avait pas en fait
il y avait pas de rodé au sens où comme
ce qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure en fait
on a des dérapages ça tourne de partout
vous n'êtes pas d'accord qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre ce genre de
la route dans tous les mariages
donc voilà donc ce qui veut c'est ce qui
est Monsieur
tout le temps non ça n'arrive pas de tir
à blanc il parlait j'ai pas dit que ça
arrivait systématiquement j'ai dit en
fait que dans certains mariages en fait
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver
évidemment pardon et on peut le
regretter d'ailleurs oui bien sûr qu'on
peut le regretter là-dessus il y a pas
de difficultés moi je suis pas moi je
suis pas en train je suis pas en train
de vous dire que le fait de sortir un
calibre et puis de tirer en fait c'est
une chose normale évidemment c'est une
bêtise absolue ça on est d'accord on est
d'accord en fait lorsque je vous donne
en fait le temps de trajet la version
exactement c'est pour montrer qu'il y a
pas il peut pas avoir de rodé ou vous me
dites c'est entre 3 et 5 minutes tu peux
pas entre 3 et 5 minutes et si vous
voulez en fait il y avait une patrie une
patrouille de police de la BAC qui était
déjà présente sur Illkirch et qui a été
alerté qui avait en fait un souci un
souci avec avec ce cortège notamment en
fait les tirs par armes à feu donc les
policiers de la de la de la BAC arrivent
très rapidement et ils voient le cortège
le cortège partir du domicile de la
future mariée du domicile de la future
marée et qui se rend en mairie donc il
les suivent ils ont à ce moment là en
fait l'identification du du véhicule et
ils recherchent ce véhicule là donc très
bien il remonte il remonte et ils
interpellent les occupants du véhicule
sur le parvis sur le parvis de la mairie
d'accord qui sont arrêtés sur le parvis
de la mairie déjà le premier correctif à
apporter il n'y a pas eu trois personnes
d'interpeller mais une seule le
conducteur le conducteur c'est le frère
le frère le frère du marié des services
de police ou pas du tout non au départ
les trois sont interpellés quand même
parce que j'étais sur place j'étais au
moment de l'interpellation après la
seule différence que j'apporterai qui
est quand même assez flagrante c'est que
contrairement à ce que vous dites certes
ils habitent pas très loin de la mairie
sauf qu'ils sont rendus ils sont donnés
rendez-vous sur un parking d'un
supermarché qui est au milieu de la
ville et à partir de là une heure avant
il commence déjà à faire un certain
nombre de faits de rodéo de choses comme
ça des drift dans la rue enfin voilà
puisqu'on a quand même des signalements
de riverain mais après il y a des vidéos
surveillance donc après on pourra
regarder les vidéos surveillance et on
pourra vous montrer que vous fatiguez
maintenant les vidéos de surveillance
moi j'ai pas accès aux deux dossier
pénal le jeune homme a été jugé hier il
a été il a été condamné il a été jugé
sur des faits de tir et c'est le cortège
en lui-même et les infractions et les
infractions n'ont pas été d'armes
illégales
de la route
quel est votre version ma version à moi
en fait donc c'est que c'est il y a une
personne qui a été interpellée et placée
en garde à vue les autres personnes
n'ont pas été interpellées elles ont
peut-être été interrogées elles ont été
elles ont assisté elles auraient pu
assister à la cérémonie donc elles ont
été laissées libres là-dessus il y a pas
que vous comprenez la décision de
Monsieur le Maire d'annuler le mariage
mais absolument pas bien évidemment
pourquoi mais c'est totalement
disproportionné en fait si vous voulez
si vous voulez en fait c'est extrêmement
simple on sanctionne qui en annulant ce
mariage les maris les mariés qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait les mariés est-ce qu'une
faute individuelle peut-être collective
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas qu'une
faute individuelle je vous reprends
parce que en fait comme parce que je
pense que visuellement vous voyez pas
forcément la scène moi je l'ai vécu donc
c'est vrai que c'est plus simple mais
quand vous voyez un cortège complet avec
justement le cortège du mariage qui fait
plein d'infractions au code de la route
moi j'estime que certes il y a le tireur
qui a son arme et tout ça pour le pour
lequel vous êtes intervenu au tribunal
mais ça n'enlève pas qu'il y a eu toutes
ces infractions au code de la route
mais toutes ces infractions au code de
la route d'accord les agents de police
pourront verbaliser les contrevenants on
est d'accord voilà donc en quoi est-ce
que les mariés sont responsables de
l'attitude qui justement qui est
d'accord avec la décision de Monsieur
maire et qui n'est pas d'accord d'accord
avec l'addition du avec le monsieur le
Maire d'accord mais oui vous êtes tous
d'accord avec l'addition
et Gilles ils ne sont pas d'accord après
vous allez nous dire ce qui ce qui veut
c'est vraiment rien demandé non mais
regardez vos pancars pourquoi Géraldine
tu es d'accord bah je vous félicite
Monsieur le Maire c'est très bien
j'espère que ça servira jurisprudence
parce qu'il y a de plus en plus de
malheureusement de mariage qui se passe
mal comme ça avec un nom sauvagement de
la société et moi je trouve que c'est
très très bien et il faudrait même qu'il
y ait une caution peut-être que même qui
rembourse certains certains frais ce
qu'il y a eu des dégradations par
exemple de de bien public en sauvagement
là vous allez loin mais vous plaisez
alors moi je n'aime pas ce mot moi en
sauvagement
des des témoins du fait qu'on voit que
la société excusez-moi sont sauvage hier
on recevait une maman avec un fils
tabassé qui est handicapé excusez-moi
des enfants qui sont harcelés parce
qu'ils sont homosexuels tout ça moi je
trouve que ça participe à
l'ensommagement parce que si tous ces
mariages ça passe sur les réseaux
sociaux donc on a l'impression qu'on
veut toujours mettre la barre plus haut
voilà en fait si vous voulez vous vous
comprenez pas du tout la décision parce
que non je comprends pas parce que
regardez en fait je vais je vais
terminer très rapidement sur les sur les
faits après on reviendra sur la question
sur la question juridique les policiers
interpellent le jeune homme à 15h30 il
leur indique spontanément où est l'arme
pour vous dire à quel point en fait les
choses se passent calmement les
policiers ne le menottent pas ne me note
pas il en place
c'était passé calmement ça c'est ça
c'est passé calmement y compris au
moment au moment de l'interpellation
maintenant en fait je voulais juste
revenir en fait sur ce que Monsieur le
Maire a dit et qui est qui est pas
conforme qui est pas conforme à la
réalité
l'annonce de l'annulation du mariage
c'est ce sont les c'est un policier de
la BAC qui l'a annoncé à la famille ce
n'est pas Monsieur le Maire d'accord ce
n'est pas l'adjoint
la famille moi j'ai 60 témoins qui
étaient dans la salle moi j'ai aussi des
témoins si vous voulez je peux les faire
tenir à la limite ça c'est du détail moi
c'est pas du détail parce que vous
prenez une décision que vous n'assumez
pas alors j'assume complètement la
décision enfin si il est là c'est qu'il
assume j'assume vous avez il y avait des
policiers j'assume complètement et tu as
des sols qui n'est pas d'accord avec
l'addition de Monsieur le Maire pas du
tout très respectueusement Monsieur le
Maire vous êtes brillant mais vous êtes
jeune récemment élu est-ce que vous
n'avez pas su réagi vous décrivez une
situation une situation
insurrectionnelle il y avait des
dizaines de policiers dans une mairie un
jour de mariage vous avez pour moi
gâcher le plus beau jour de la vie de
ces futurs mariés j'espère je ne
comprends pas je trouve que vous avez
été bien trop loin d'ailleurs vous
pouvez être attaqué au tribunal c'est
presque vous avez presque ou de repassé
vos fonctions non j'ai pas autre passé
mes fonctions j'ai exercé mon pouvoir de
police et comme j'estime qu'à partir du
moment où je ne peux pas garantir qu'en
sortant de la mairie ensuite il y ait
pas de troubles à l'ordre public la
décision que j'ai prise elle a été prise
en discutant aussi avec les policiers
qui m'ont tout à fait soutenu et avec
les différentes institutions qui m'ont
soutenu donc moi j'ai pris cette
décision parce que j'estime
qu'aujourd'hui et je le vois de mes
concitoyens de la part de mes
concitoyens et d'ailleurs tous les
messages sur les réseaux sociaux le
prouvent bien et puis je suis pas des
amis c'est vraiment des habitants qui en
ont marre qui en ont marre de voir c'est
finalement ces gens qui dépassent les
lois ces gens et vous dites ces gens qui
font ces gens ces personnes par exemple
dans ce cortège comme dans les rodéo
urbains où on a l'impression que
finalement
ces personnes là s'en sortent tout le
temps et puis les gens qui respectent
tout bah on les embête et c'est vraiment
dommage parce que moi je célèbre des
mariages il y a plein de mariages qui se
passent très bien moi j'estime qu'un
cortège de mariage ça peut très bien se
passer vous savez le jour d'un mariage
c'est un jour de fête mais c'est pas une
parenthèse avec les lois le jour du
mariage c'est un jour important où on
respecte encore la loi et on respecte
ses concitoyens et on se respecte
soi-même parce que en faisant des
infractions code de la route on se fait
même en danger soi-même donc c'est quand
même dommage de se gâcher sa propre fête
trois feu rouge grillées trois coups de
klaxon oui ok pour les tirs de ce ok
pour les tirs de ce monde la personne a
été condamnée
mais là franchement Monsieur le Maire
vous décrivez une situation on a
l'impression qu'il y avait des émotes
dans la ville c'est pas ça du tout
c'était une communauté qui avait envie
de célébrer un mariage
je vous pouvez donner le prénom des
mariés par exemple ils sont de
confessions musulmane
je demande très respectueusement Homère
est-ce que le fait que ces gens étaient
de confessions musulmane à influer sur
votre décision
non mais excusez-moi j'ai posé une
question
en quoi c'est honteux de poser une
question maintenant si on va pouvoir
poser des questions
moi j'estime que c'est pourquoi j'ai une
pose cette question c'est pas des propos
corrects je trouve ça vraiment
dommageable parce que au quotidien je
célèbre des mariages avec
peu importe qui sont les habitants de ma
ville ce sont les habitants de ma ville
mais après en tant que mère j'ai un
devoir de protéger ma population et là
j'estime avoir protégé ma population
parce que il y avait des débordeurs
les habitants ont ressenti ça comme des
débordements donc un moment j'ai pris
une mesure qui me semble la bonne mesure
à prendre parce que effectivement moi je
souhaite que ça devienne une
jurisprudence que la loi se renforce sur
ses sur ce domaine là parce que je vois
que ce phénomène est en augmentation il
faut arrêter que ce phénomène augmente
en France on peut très bien que
klaxonner on peut très bien avoir les
feux de détresse on peut mettre de la
musique on peut on peut célébrer on peut
passer des très bons moments à des
mariages sans forcément ne pas respecter
les règles alors
moi je me placerai pas en fait sur ce
terrain là en fait il y a strictement
aucun élément en fait dans le dossier
pour considérer en fait que ça a été
prise en considération en fait de la
religion des personnes ça en fait je ne
place pas du tout je préfère utiliser
ces arguments en fait quand j'ai des
éléments objectifs qui ne le permettent
une hypothèse en fait à laquelle je ne
peux pas
le dossier pénal en fait ne l'indique
pas moi tout ce que je vois en fait vous
Monsieur le Maire en fait moi j'ai un
dossier pénal donc je vois en fait ce
que juridiquement les policiers ont fait
quand vous dites que votre décision a
été pris en concertation avec avec la
police etc etc c'est faux c'est faux
vous prenez cette décision au pied levé
de façon totalement irréfléchie les
policiers en réfère à leur hiérarchie
qui leur envoient qui leur envoie du
renfort mais à aucun moment la décision
n'a été prise en concertation vous
l'avez pris à 15h30 lors du placement en
garde à vue quand les policiers vous ont
indiqué qu'ils avaient interpellé le
contrevenant à ce moment-là on sait que
c'est une arme c'est une réplique d'un
Glock 9 mm un pistolet d'alarme donc on
le sait mais évidemment quand les tirent
visiblement puisqu'il a le droit de
devenir effectivement comme il a dit le
patron de la police quand il considère
que il y a un danger il avait le droit
de prendre des décisions même sans arrêt
il faut distinguer deux choses il faut
distinguer deux choses les troubles qui
a eu avant le rodéo très bien là-dessus
en fait je ne discute pas si il y a des
infractions qui ont été commises je vous
le dis tout de suite les policiers ont
exploité les vidéos surveillance il y a
pas de vidéo surveillance donc les
contrevenants en fait ils seront jamais
ils ont jamais ils ont jamais de
contrevention la seule personne qui a
été sanctionné qui ont été dressés il y
a 5 PvE qui ont été dressing mais ça on
va pas rentrer
les téléspectateurs il y en a qui disent
le maire il y en a qui pensent le maire
aurait dû arrêter les personnes et les
scénarios se faire et il y en a qui
disent au contraire les mariés au lieu
de dire à leurs potes calmos parce que
voilà vous allez me flinguer au mariage
donc voilà c'est les deux des deux des
voilà les deux vidéos qui ressortent il
y avait il y avait il y avait une autre
solution extrêmement simple Monsieur le
Maire ce qu'il a pris en fait ça
s'appelle une mesure de police de police
administrative le principe c'est qu'elle
doit être proportionnée elle doit être
proportionnée or là en fait elle ne
l'est pas vous aviez une autre faculté
très simple c'était de reporter de
reporter vous dites écoutez vu le bordel
que vous avez foutu moi je peux pas
mettre que ça se passe comme ça dans ma
commune
aujourd'hui il y a rien qui qui
en tout cas il y a rien qui empêche ils
sont pas revenu vers la mairie donc ça
veut dire que vous n'avez même pas pris
un arrêté mais il y a il y a rien qui
empêche ils sont pas là
on a fait on a fait la procédure mais
rien n'empêche je revienne à la mairie
refaire des smashs est-ce que vous avez
pris un arrêté est-ce que vous avez pris
un arrêté spécial tout un arrêté
individuel est-ce que vous l'avez
notifié
ce soir mais il est 21h13 voilà qu'on
pense un peu aux mariés qu'on pense à
vous etc est-ce que vous voulez pas
est-ce que vous voulez pas refaire
L'Oréal ou les mariez-vous ça se calme
il faut un cortège voilà
calme voilà mais c'est sympathique dans
la joie et que ce soit vous qui mariez
ces deux personnes comme ça tout se
termine bien et comme ça on repart à
depuis le départ sur cette affaire là
j'ai toujours dit que moi ça me posait
aucun souci de procéder au mariage mais
de procéder au mariage dans le calme
dans la quiétude et que tout se passe
dans la loi moi franchement il y a aucun
souci et moi je trouve que vraiment en
tant qu'élu de la République un des plus
beaux moments franchement qu'on est à
faire quand on est mère ou adjoint au
maire c'est quand même de marier les
gens enfin de lire les gens est-ce que
les moments sympas quoi les mariés j'ai
envie de se marier toujours là dans
cette mairie ou pas
non ils sont plutôt dégoûtés en fait
mais après bon si ça peut si ça peut
aller plus vite parce que là c'est
problématique il y a un voyage de noces
qui a été prévu l'autre mariage est
organisé depuis un an et que ça serait
quand le délai parce que j'adore donner
des dates dans cette émission on est le
11 octobre est-ce qu'il peut est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut trouver un créneau
cette semaine moi je sais pas je peux
pas m'engager pour mes clients en fait
non mais non mais il faut il faut que ça
évite parce que c'est quand le voyage de
noces d'ici deux semaines donc d'ici
deux semaines que c'est possible ou pas
en tout cas il faut voir avec mes
services mais moi
on demandera quand même des gages pour
pas qu'il y ait débordement
cette fois Cyril ça serait génial que le
maire Marie c'est c'est marier ça serait
génial ça serait une belle APN
franchement tout non ça c'est pas enfin
un mariage oui c'est possible mais de
toute façon en fait il y aura une action
en justice parce qu'en fait comme
Monsieur le Maire en fait veut faire
jurisprudence pour moi en fait sa
décision utile légale c'est pas possible
je peux pas laisser passer ça alors un
tribunal tranchera si Monsieur le Maire
a raison eh ben tant mieux si Monsieur
le Maire a tort la commune sera qu'on
sera condamné et voilà